good evening welcome to quill rich books
of music we're so pleased that we have
such a good crowd to hear about this
extraordinary book and that is
extraordinary I'm constantly amazed at
the judgment and the decisions good
decisions of Algonquin books to publish
these wonderful books they publish but
this one took me to a higher admiration
particularly of Shannon Ravenel under
whose imprint the book was published but
I can certainly see why she did it I
wish you were here to tell you herself
but she'll be here later for you to talk
to after the program I was astounded
when I read this book I would evoked so
many emotions in me that I thought I
didn't want to do this because I would
probably get emotional but as you can
see I'm perfectly calm and I'll tell you
about Tim Duncan and he will introduce
our other honored guests Tim was born
was raised in Washington DC and the end
the Chesapeake Bay Area the settings for
both of his novels I'll tell you about
those he graduated from the University
of Maryland with honors and from
Georgetown University Law School and in
1977 he began his legal career as a
District of Columbia public defender he
defended in several notable murder
trials before becoming a national trial
lawyer in private practice he has taught
at the writers Center at Georgetown
Harvard Law School and American
University where he received its adjunct
professor of the Year award
Kirk is the author of two award-winning
novels grand
I'm sorry Good Counsel which was
published in 2000 and the watermen in
nineteen
99 they got great reviews they were very
exciting reads and they were novels this
is his first nonfiction book let me just
read a couple of brief reviews of this
book from Scott Turow it says the story
his story Bloodworth story is not only
memorable and important but gripping and
revelatory more than anything
Bloodsworth is a tale of courage and
determination in the face of the laws
worst nightmare the execution of an
innocent man Joseph Wambaugh the
esteemed writer says Bloodsworth may
well be the most incredible and
important true story ever written about
a death-row convicts daily battle for
survival both in the cellblock and in
the courtrooms the reader will be swept
along to an amazing and shocking
conclusion that could never be believed
as fiction and there were many other
starred reviews and just excellent
reviews of this wonderful book I would
like for you to welcome Tim Chunkin
[Applause]
Nancy thank you so much and thanks to
whale reg books and everybody else has
supported this event and thank you all
for coming out tonight we appreciate it
very much Kirk and I have been in the
raleigh-durham area now for two days we
appeared at UNC law school yesterday
spoke to about 300 young law students
and I think perhaps Kirk particularly
made them think about things they never
thought about before and perhaps the
going to do a little better lawyers of
all those things at goop oops law school
as well and made the same reaction it's
a real thrill to be here with Kirk and I
think you are in for a real treat when
you get the opportunity to go from him
now we're on c-span so I have a lot of
friends here tonight I don't want any
tech money from I am as Nancy alluded to
like I grew up firmly on the Eastern
Shore of Maryland which is a Jessica any
country and the term for a Chesapeake
Bay fisherman or crabber is a Waterman
I actually spent a year trying to be a
Waterman before sort of rounds in the
middle of college but it was way too
hard so I opted for something a lot
easier and went to law school Kirk of
course is a bit of wood him in all his
life and comes from of that has
generations of Waterman hey my first
book was called the Waterman my first
novel my second book was set on the bag
as well and I've always had an affinity
and interest in that area and those
kinds of people I remember that I had
been a public defender and I just
started a private practice I've been in
private practice for a few years was
about 1984 and I heard this story I
heard a press report that there has been
an Eastern Shore Waterman from Cambridge
round we've been arrested and charged
with the rape and murder of a little
girl and having spent many years with
Waterman and with those kinds of people
perhaps it was a bit naive a romantic on
my part but people who live on the water
who are sort of part of the the rhythms
of the Bay and the natural world I just
it just seemed incongruous to me to time
that a water man would commit a crime
like that and that he's didn't Illya but
I was very busy in Washington DC
building up my wall practice and I kind
of lost track of the story after I
written my second novel I was sort of
casting around I wanted to do a
nonfiction book and I came across an
article it was about 20 years later I
actually wondered that and it was about
that same Waterman and it was about how
he had been exonerated he had been
convicted of the crime sentenced to
death exonerated and it talked about
what a difficult time he was having
coming back into his community from
prison
it got me thinking since Kirk was a
Waterman I you know I had that interest
I had worked on death penalty cases
myself I mean the justice system pretty
well so I contacted Kirk Bloodsworth
really knowing very little about his
story and asked him if he would consider
working with me on a project of writing
writing what had happened to him in a
book I told him that I would want to
have artistic control and try to write a
very objective story of what happened
through his cooperation and I agreed to
make it a collaborative effort and after
some discussions I took them in the
water men and like that
felt that I perhaps could understand
some things about him to others might
not and we started to drive yet they're
worse you gotta have my cheat sheet here
Ariane's for me first of all I didn't
know about the circumstances of the
crime
in 1984 in July on a warm summer day
around 11 o'clock in the morning in a
suburb of Baltimore a young girl it was
nine-years-old who was named Denise
Hamilton dawn Venise Hamilton without
playing with some friends around 11
o'clock in the morning her mother went
out to find her or her guardian went out
to find her and couldn't again looking
frantically for her in the area came
across two young boys ages 7 and 9 and
asked them if they'd seen dawn and they
told her that Dawn had gone into the
woods with a strange man Thorne's
Guardian called the police eventually
over two hundred police officers were
involved in a search for gone tragically
about three o'clock that afternoon they
found her in the woods she was brutally
murdered she'd been sexually assaulted
her head had been crushed her throat had
been stepped on so that there was to the
point where there was a footprint in her
throat she was naked from the waist down
a large stick had been thrust up inside
her it was a monstrous terrible crime
and of course the community was
horrified terrified and the police
indicated that they were going to pull
out all stops the entire police force
was going to work on solving the crime
the FBI would be involved it was it was
a very tragic moment at around that time
Kirk Bloodsworth was a decorated Marine
who had never been arrested for anything
in his life he had married a woman ten
years older than he was and it was a
brief marriage and a difficult marriage
and they had lived in Cambridge for a
little while and then his wife had left
him and gone to Baltimore and he had
followed her up to Baltimore to try to
patch up the marriage and was been up
there for approximately three weeks when
this murder occurred and he lived in a
group house with his wife and some of
her relatives about a mile away
he was walking everywhere he was the
only one in the house who worked because
she had wrecked a car but he knew
nothing about the
crime until he heard about it on
television in researching the book
another thing I didn't know when I first
met Kirk Bloodsworth was was how people
always say to me how could a man who had
never been arrested in his life how
could such a man be targeted arrested
indicted tried convicted and sentenced
to death for a crime he didn't commit I
was able to gather together thousands of
all the thousands of the police reports
there were over 300 tips that came in to
the police department and there were
literally thousands of police reports
police notes police interviews all of
the FBI forensic reports the the
pleadings the grand jury transcripts the
trial transcripts and I try to piece
together in the book for the reader sort
of from the minds of the two lead
homicide detectives in this case how
they came to believe that this man
committed this monstrous crime and they
did come to believe that the two boys
two little boys in composite drawings
the composite drawings were disseminated
in the community there were inconsistent
descriptions of the assailant that they
gave eventually the police located a
number of adults who they claimed saw
the strange man by the pond that day by
the boys but the book traces how these
police officers and their zeal to find
this person not with malice they were
trying to find the killer but came to
believe that the wrong man did it and
then how they began to contort the
evidence adult eyewitnesses were
contacted the weekend before the lineup
right after Kirk Bloodsworth was
arrested and they were told we're gonna
have a lineup on Monday so don't watch
the television this weekend because if
you do you might see the suspect what do
you think these eyewitnesses dead
several of them were glued to the
television so that they saw this man in
handcuffs and shackles surrounded by
police and then when they went to the
lineup on Monday who would they
recognize
the book traces unfortunately the many
kind of classic mistakes that police and
prosecutors make in cases like this
withholding of evidence poor
identification testimony they got Kurt
Bloodsworth to make some statements
which were consistent with innocence but
which they interpreted to be consistent
with guilt to the point where they ended
up believing that he was the man there
was an FBI psychological profile done in
this case back in 1984 profiling was a
very new art and the FBI tried to
develop a psychological picture of the
kind of sick person who would commit
this crime and a psychological profile
conveniently or coincidentally had
things in it like well probably someone
who hates women probably someone who is
dominated by an older woman the man who
did this will probably leave the scene
within a few days after the crime things
like that one of the tips that the
police got was filed by his wife when
Kirk left her she was so mad she found a
missing-persons report they called up
Kirk's job they found out he'd left two
or three days after the crime they found
that he was married to a woman ten years
older than him they began to misuse
really what a psychological profile is
supposed to be used for all of these
little mistakes one after another and
you can see as you read the book how
they became so convinced this man was
was guilty of this crime before Kirk
Bloodsworth I bet hundreds of people
said to me you know innocent people
can't get convicted of these crimes and
they certainly can't get convicted twice
this book shows that that's wrong when I
first met Kirk Bloodsworth I didn't know
much about him yet he was in Eastern
Shore tornament I knew but his history
as a decorated marine as a discus
thrower his aspirations for the future
and then what happened to him on the
very night that he was uh arrested and
thrown into this horror that went on for
ten years I didn't know that when the
judge after his first trial
sentenced him to die in the gas chamber
but a courtroom more crowded and packed
in this room erupted in cheers and
applause people screamed give him the
gas give him the gas as he fell to his
knees wondering how could these people
be cheering I'm an innocent man when I
first met Kirk Bloodsworth I didn't know
that he had been tried not once but
twice for this crime and convicted by
two different juries two different
judges after Kirk's first trial his
family his father his mother they
mortgaged their house they took out
their life savings
his first lawyer was a court-appointed
lawyer after he was granted a new trial
because of prosecutorial misconduct
because prosecutors withheld exculpatory
evidence the first time around about
another suspect his parents took
everything they had to hire what they
thought would be the finest lawyer in
Baltimore County who promised Kirk that
he'd be out having a steak dinner as
soon as the second trial was over the
second lawyer entirely different
strategy in the case if you read the
book you'll see the first case there
were alibi witnesses that were character
witnesses Kirk testified in the second
trial the lawyer decided to put none of
those people on to simply just to try to
attack the government's case case they
trial went on for two weeks same verdict
guilty when I first met Kirk Bloodsworth
I had no idea about his experiences in
prison thrown into one of the most
violent and notorious prisons in the
United States the south wing of the
Maryland penitentiary were a week before
he got there a guard had been
disemboweled by an inmate over perceived
insult so that the guards when Kirk got
there all wore knife vests here he was
thrown into this environment branded a
child murderer a child killer he was
everybody's target and after about two
months they put him out in general
population Kirk opened up to me about
some of his experiences in prison book
details some of the things he had to do
to survive and the environment he lived
in and it is truly bone-chilling stuff
I don't think anybody can read the book
without asking themselves could I have
even survived this let alone triumphed
over it when Kirk Bloodsworth was in
prison his lawyers appealed his second
conviction and that appeal was turned
down he lost and it seemed like all hope
was over for him second judge have it
was troubled by the the evidence in the
case and so sentence Kirk instead of to
die he sentenced him to two consecutive
life sentences the second judge was so
disturbed by the evidence
in addition that he kept the the clothes
the panties and the shorts of Don
Hamilton and the stick in a closet in
his chambers because he knew that after
the second appeal once it was denied
that in a matter of time the evidence
would be destroyed and he thought them
to himself even though DNA nobody knew
of DNA back then that maybe one day
someone might need this evidence
Kirk story in fact is full of these
little miracles you read in the book
that at the first trial the FBI tested
the little girl's shorts and her panties
and an FBI agent came into court under
oath and testified that there was no
identifiable sperm on any of the clothes
now get back to that in a minute what
Kirk Bloodsworth did was every single
day of his life in prison he wrote
letters he wrote thousands of letters
every one was signed Kirk Bloodsworth a
period I period and period an innocent
man
he wrote him to everybody he could think
of he never stopped telling everybody he
meant that he was innocent he never gave
up and he finally got in touch with a
man named Bob Moore and happens to be a
friend of mine a prince of a man is now
a judge and he convinced by morning to
come see him and Bob Morin was busy at
the time and was actually seeing Kirk
for a friend but after 45 minutes Kirk
convinced Bob Morton that he was
innocent of this crime and Bob Morin
took on his cause that was in 1989 and
around that time Kirk read a book he was
reading avidly everything to get his
hands on it might help him he read a
book by
the California crime writer Joe wamba
about the first use of DNA to solve a
criminal case it happened in England and
Kurt read this book and he thought to
himself you know maybe maybe this is the
miracle I need and he contacted Bob
Bob's first reaction was Kirk there's
nothing to test
there was no sperm the FBI tested all
the clothing that were swabs taken there
was no sperm there was no foreign blood
and Kirk said you know Bob I want you to
pursue this I want you to follow it up I
want you to check it out
and Bob more and found the clothes that
still existed in the judges closet in
his chambers and convinced the
prosecutors in the court to let him have
it sent out to that for this new
developing science called DNA and in
fact there was a new DNA technique at
the time and one lab in the country then
you had to do it where you could take a
small small piece of biological specimen
and amplify it into enough so that you
could test and they sent it out to that
lab in California I took about three
years of battling with the prosecutors
and with the courts and getting the
tests done Bob Moore the lawyer put up
ten thousand dollars of his own money
it was own money to have this test done
and it came back and the PhD the
scientist in California said there was a
semen stain the size of a quarter right
in the middle of the girls panties and
it was not Kirk Bloodsworth when I first
met Kirk Bloodsworth I didn't know that
after he was loud a prison the
prosecutors this was in nineteen ninety
three instead of apologizing issued a
statement they had a press release and
they said this evidence calls into
question mr. Bloodsworth guilt but we're
not prepared to say he's innocent that's
the press release that the prosecutors
issued Kirk Bloodsworth went back to
Cambridge Maryland people in Cambridge
Maryland didn't know what DNA was they
thought it was another legal quick step
you know some fancy legal trick to get
him out of jail they thought he was a
murderer a child killer people left
messages on his truck
child murderer child killer people
chased him out of name
hoods when he tried to work the Kirk
wasn't satisfied and just triumphing
over the injustice that was done to him
he felt that he was joined at the hip
with this little girl who was killed
they were double victims of this crime
and he set out to solve the crime itself
and he began pestering the prosecutors
to take that DNA that he and Bob Morin
had discovered and put it in the county
database or the state database or the
national database and let's look for
this person this this monster out there
who might still be killing other people
they wouldn't do it 10 years went by 10
years of Kirk Bloodsworth writing them
calling them getting lawyers to hound
them until enough pressure build up and
there were there were articles in the
papers and lawyers were calling them
that they finally agreed to put the DNA
in the database I was halfway through
writing this manuscript and we didn't
know who the killer was and I got this
call from Kirk and he was shaking and
crying they finally just a year ago put
the DNA in the in the in the database
and it identified the actual murderer
incredibly it was a man who was in
prison in the same prison tear as Kirk
Bloodsworth who lifted weights with Kirk
Bloodsworth for five years
Kirk solved that solved that crime and
that man pled guilty this past March and
admitted that he killed Don Hamilton by
himself in 1984 and finally Kirk an
apology from the prosecutors when I
first met Kirk Bloodsworth probably the
most incredible thing of all as I
learned or I learned as I was working on
the case and learned it from him and
about him was what he has done with his
life after coming out of prison you know
most of us I think after an experience
like that would be so bitter so angry
alcoholic
just just to destroy life Kirk has
become he's turned his life from being
one of a victim of the most profound
type of injustice and to being one of
our nation's great spokespersons for
justice he goes around the country in
the world now he's appeared in front of
Congress a dozen times he's in pure
appeared in front of half of our state
legislatures speaking he's working right
now on legislation in Congress that has
passed the House and is pending before
the Senate part of it's named after him
to try to provide DNA testing from
inmates who meet certain criteria who
might be innocent and also to provide
funds for DNA for tests of rape kits
there's 300,000 women out there who've
been raped and there are rape kits of
their of their assailants with their DNA
and the states say they don't have
enough money to test them
that means 300,000 rapist on the loose
300,000 victims who can't get justice
and those are the kind of things Kirk
Bloodsworth works for and that's what he
does this past March the man who
invented the DNA fingerprint Sir Alec
Jeffrey's was honored in Great Britain
with Britain's lifetime achievement
award in front of a televised audience
of 10 million Brits and they flew Kirk
Bloodsworth over to London to appear on
stage with Sir Alec Jeffrey's and that's
the kind of impact he has had he speaks
at law schools he's trying to teach law
students not to making mistakes that
these prosecutors made he's trying to
teach young lawyers who are going to be
prosecutors it's not about gamesmanship
it's not about winning that there are
higher more important goals and duties
if you're going to be a prosecutor if
you're gonna be a lawyer this is what
he's devoted his life to one of the
people who reviewed this book said you
know what Kirk Bloodsworth did to
overcome what happened to him he's truly
an act of triumph but what he's done
with his life since there's nothing less
than an act of grace and I think that's
true
I'm very proud tonight to be part of
this book it's been a great honor for me
to work with Kirk and I'm proud to
introduce him tonight ladies and
gentlemen Kirk Bloodsworth I want to
thank Nancy and rich books and for
having me here tonight it's an honor and
a privilege if you'd have told me 20
years ago I'll be standing in a
bookstore North Carolina I'd said you
was absolutely crazy I want to tell you
a story about the first lawyer I had
there was in a visiting room in the
Towson Detention Center in Baltimore
County they had you know little boost
and you get on the phone and I know some
people here wouldn't understand what I'm
saying and it was a brick wall right
behind me just like this here there's
archway doors on either side and there's
no door there 8 foot tall 10 foot wide
you can walk right through them or drive
a car so my first lawyer comes out to me
and he goes mr. Bloodsworth I know my
way around criminal justice and I know
my way around a courtroom and I'm gonna
find our way out of this situation keeps
going on and on and on and I'm starting
to feel blue Lantis guys okay he knows
his way around a courtroom he says I
know my way around a criminal justice
and I know my way around a Baltimore
County justice system way more like just
for 20 minutes
finally he got up and put his hand on
the glass and said Kirk I know my way
around a criminal justice system and
we're gonna find our way out of this
situation takes his coat grabs his
briefcase says goodbye turns around runs
right into the wall I'm done but on
August 9th 1984 it wasn't so funny open
up it's a Baltimore County police
department I was living down in
Cambridge over in the door and I had a
pair of shorts on silk running shorts no
shirt no should be no shoes that was
sleeping this quarter to 3:00 in the
morning opened the door and that guy
flatulating my face and said there he is
I turned right around looking for
somebody else honestly I did he says
you're under arrest for the first-degree
murder of Don Venise hand with a molten
you sob huh no no sir no no no no no I
didn't do it I didn't do it I'm not
guilty I'm an innocent man we don't want
to hear that turn me around put the
handcuffs on me you have a right to
remain silent anything you say can and
will be used against you they mean that
when they say that - and put me in the
police car
and I never seen it Cambridge again for
eight years 11 months and 19 days two of
those years on death row I went to one
of the hardest prisons in the United
States the Maryland penitentiary 954
fourth Street there's somebody in the
back here I want to introduce to him
later that knows about that place some I
sitting right up front here that knows
about how prison is well I went to the
first trial and the witnesses said that
they were looking for a man that was six
foot five curly blond hair a bushy
mustache
skin and skinny I was not skinny in 1984
and I'm certainly not now I weighed 225
pounds I was six foot tall I was a lot
leaner but I was far from skinny I had
red hair well the trial come around all
of a sudden demanding six foot five no
more he's six foot something early funny
how stuff like that changes but there
was two little boys and you can't blame
these two little boys they were two
witnesses indication they saw the man
sitting up on a rise of a hill looking
up at him with the Sun behind his head
they were eight and ten years old
neither one of them picked me out of the
lineup until two weeks later saying no
we made a mistake one pick number three
and now them we didn't pick anybody it
was number six I stood in the sixth
position when the police sketches
artists were putting the composite
together it's a set of overlays it's
called a ident kit and it's made by
Disney and it's a set of a set of noses
set of ears set of lips and all that and
the little boy looked at Dumanis it well
I'm not happy with the composite well
one aren't you happy about he said I
don't like the mustache the eyes okay
but I don't like the mustache and the
hair is wrong when did y'all don't look
quite right he said what kind of
mustache wasn't he says that one right
there and a man showed him to him said
that's a foo Manchu little boy said I
don't know where the food Manchu is but
that's what it looked like on the police
officers on his own but the mustache did
the boy didn't like on the subject now I
want you to remember how six foot five
we heard that right and six foot on what
you remember that - and remember 225
pounds in skinny because that's
important also
I was convicted I was convicted with a
courtroom erupting as somebody score a
touchdown and a Carolina Panthers game
I'm a Ravens fan but I'm sorry but if
you know what I'm talking about and what
the heck am I going to do I'm going to
the Maryland penitentiary accused of
killing a nine-year-old girl and my butt
is in trouble
the first night I was in jail I heard
this sound we're gonna get you and they
meant that but there I gave as good as I
got it didn't help me sometimes I got
hit in the back of here with a sock full
of batteries I've seen I knew a fella by
the name of blue remember blue don't you
and blue was a guy he was a range of
known rapist see he he admitted to his
guilt and blue hated prison so bad that
he took two pencils and rammed them
right in his eyeball to get out of jail
he I mean literally just shoved them
right in his eyes and he was a guilty
man how did you think I felt but no I
wanted to see cuz I wanted to read I
read over 3,000 books in prison
everything from Steven Keeny to get
start psychology forget that lasting
because I can't understand it if I told
you it's the dryer saying it's my mouth
right now excuse me
but I'm just a man I tried it survived
the best way I knew how
and reading was my thing that was my
escape I took a little Lewis and more
novels and Stephen King novels because
any horror story he wrote went near as
bad as what I was going through I read
everything I could get my hands on legal
papers anything about discovery anything
about the evidence in in how its
obtained how prosecutors are supposed to
act how he's supposed to treat a
defendant anything and everything I
could and I wrote that many letters to
everybody in the state from Willie
Nelson to Ronald Reagan I never got no
answer for Ronald or Willie but I still
wrote in our wrote and I wrote and I
wrote I used to write the judge I said
it's Christmas Eve and I'm still in jail
an innocent man
all right period excuse me a period a
period M period every single letter now
prison the first night I was there in
the Maryland penitentiary I remember
being on the South for Union they used
to feed you up with styrofoam cups and I
had spaghetti that night but it was a
half ball - made in my cup and I threw
it back and ate it and just started
crying the door sounded like the back of
a dump truck falling down on the back of
the bed and slamming shut and my life
was over you're talking to a fella that
went to a Christian school in eleventh
and twelfth grade and never been
arrested for anything in my life
nothing never I was I'll be discharged
from the Marine Corps I was a discus
champion all marine discus champion for
three years now I'm not telling to tell
you I was angel with wings because I
certainly not true but I would now kill
in a non you're a little girl
I got my case overturned by a thin
lining in law called Brady evidence and
that's exculpatory evidence attends and
engage your guilt whether or not you
committed a crime if you have any
evidence that says somebody else did it
they're supposed to give it to you I
mean that's the law they have to give it
to you if you file a motion to say they
you give us all the stuff and don't hold
nothing back what did the state do they
had another suspect they came in today
to murder in a psychologic psychiatric
clinic five minutes away had scratches
on his face and was wearing the same
clothes it's last seen of the person
running away from the scene said he had
a problem with a little girl they kept
that evidence for two years while I sat
on death Road never told a soul as a
matter of fact he never told a soul
until the day before my trial was over
on the second time around and he said
well you should go to ask for a
continuance to ask the lawyer again I
was convicted the second time I went
back in prison in 1986 sat on the south
wing looking at the windows in this
place I'm telling you the south wing is
tim was alluding to was a bad place they
opened the windows in the wintertime it
be 30 degrees in yourself in the summer
they shot him in to be 115 I had to live
under that kind of stuff and it's hard
but I got harder I just kept writing
people and reading it writing and I
picked up this foot one day that
mysteriously come to myself and you know
that little company that you can take
pennies and get three books or three
records I've got books because I didn't
have a record player and so you come to
my door and and I don't remember ordered
I had no idea that I ordered those books
I thought I ordered something else and
the top of the book was called the
bloody about a book about the Norberto
murders in England to make a long story
short they DNA tested
a population of 20 to 30 years of age in
knauber Oh
for these little girls murders over
there and found a man by the name of
Colin pitchfork he confessed to two
crimes
BAM I had an idea whoa wait a minute
if I can convict somebody maybe that
could save you convicts a view I'm
thinking that way I was so excited I
called Bob morning on the phone I said
Bob you got to help me
there's this new thing I've called DNA
he said there's nothing there
he said but I'm gonna write the state's
attorney's office and they got some
swabs and they got some evidence and
we're going to see what they got they
had oral swabs vaginal swabs and some
other things had like three or four
different kinds of swabbing
we got the letter back from the
prosecutor's office do you know what she
said I'm sorry to inform you mr.
Bloodsworth but the swabbing have been
inadvertently destroyed I was done I
just do it
so kept pestering Bob I called him every
day but he's got a phone bill down to
the floor and that ain't no law I'm
serious I called him every day drove him
absolutely crazy he said you got to stop
calling me I said Bob when I get out
I'll stop calling you
so anyway I kept fighting I kept
fighting I kept fighting finally we got
the state degree to do all the DNA guess
what it was in the closet of the judge
he was so upset by the vergis Tim said
that he held that stuff he told the
prosecuting attorney in my case he said
this isn't about gamesmanship were
playing this is about the truth you have
to speak about the truth I knew I was on
to something we had to hold the stick I
was talking about and there's a I'm not
going to get too graphic for you because
you had to read the book because it's
very graphic stuff and I think I'll need
to let you read this book and understand
because she died a horrible death her
head was crushed with a rock her throat
was stepped on and her panties and
shorts was just discarded into a tree
and the stick I was talking about was
inserted in her body so fortunately it
passed through a part of her Anatomy
it's a god-awful thing to have a
nine-year-old early girl and have that
happen to her but I think we need to
find out who the real person was and I
was always under the feeling that if I
found that guy you know that six foot
five guy I was going to get get my
justice justice so we did the DNA test
in 1992 in dis enough this next part
bothers me very much and I can't it's
hard for me to talk about it even to
this day on April 27th 1993 we got the
DNA test back
January the 20th my mother died and I
did get see her picks up in handcuffs in
shackles for five minutes in front of
the casket that was my life I thought it
was all of them I didn't even want to
live it no more
I really didn't but she would have
wanted me to do something else because
she knew her son and I'm just a man
folks I'm just a man I'm no different
than any one of y'all sent here but I
knew I had to live and I knew had to
prove that truth I've talked about so
June 28 1993 I stepped out of Maryland
penitentiary a free man they dropped all
the charges but the prosecuting attorney
in her dropping all the charges said
this if we had to evidence in 1984 we
would never have prosecuted mr.
Bloodsworth but we are not prepared to
say he's innocent now how in the world
do you believe that the burden of proof
is on the state they should not throw
the burden of proof on an innocent
person again but they did and they did
it for 11 years after my release I
begged people I talked to Barry Scheck
in every lawyer I could find please
please get him to do the dakotas test
please do it we had to threaten him with
soot we don't have the money they said
I'll pay you the money I'll give it to
you out of my pocket please try to do
this you know I'm not against law
enforcement I was a Marine Corps
military police officer you do something
wrong got to pay the price that's my
motto that's always been my motto my
parents my father's motto you do
something wrong you got to do it
excuse me
so what was I gonna do I had to go out
and get a job what are you gonna do when
you go to a job have you ever been
convicted of a crime before yes but I
didn't do it well what do you mean I was
pardoned by the governor of the state of
Maryland I got three hundred thousand
dollars which comes to about nine
dollars and ninety seven cents a day
from my trouble I had people at work
putting child killer in the dirt on my
pickup I keep it cleaner now but people
were always calling me and harass me
people would turn I had a lady in a
supermarket one time picked up a little
girl and ran out so you don't be around
him he takes children that was monthly
but then again one day in September of
last year
I mean 94 came 95 96 97 98 99 2001 2002
2003 I get this phone call sit Baltimore
County Maryland on my caller ID
who is that so I'll pick the phone up my
cell hello and this voice came on real
Stern and businesslike and said I like
to speak to Kirk Bloodsworth please and
I said who's calling
mrs. Ambrose says the Baltimore County
Prosecutor's Office the same woman that
called me a monster and sentenced me to
die so I said the only thing I thought I
could say at that point what can I do
for you she said I want to talk to you
about a development in the Hamilton case
okay she said I'll meet you anywhere but
I have to speak to you in person
you're not coming to my house so I did
anything I thought I would do I met her
at the Burger King and I did and I had
to lose the Choptank River that's right
runs right through Cambridge there and
that's where I crab at or used to I'm
kind of busy these days but I was
crabbing there and had my boat right
there so I could take off and she was
coming by I wasn't going back to jail
but no I went there with my lawyer my
wife and my cousin we all went and she
we sat down to this table we joined
tables together and here's this woman
did hated me for twenty years sitting in
front of me eat more crowed and then in
these fields around here and told me she
said we got the real killer we got and I
said who is who did this thing name was
Kimberly shave Ruffner they're not flip
ray down I gave this man a library book
just like his close as I am to you
he'd never stand me in our he'd always
look like that or look away you know
what I mean look away scared of you you
know what I'm saying
worried anybody want to know how tall
Kim Lachey Ruffner was five foot seven a
hundred and seventy pounds and Kimberly
muffler had a foo man whew
now my life has been real different
since then I won't stand for innocent
person be in jail
never and on death Road no way happening
not while I'm standing all watch and
I've been to Congress every car every
senator in the US Senate has a copy this
book I've made some other senators give
it to him and they do - everybody's got
a copy and they passed out of the
Judiciary Committee this week a part of
the bill is called a Kirk Bloodsworth
DNA testing program and also to Debbie
Smith backlog rape kit testing program
as Tim was talking about earlier 300,000
rape kits untested in California a
couple years ago they threw 1,800 in the
garbage can because they didn't have
room for him to store him anymore that's
300 thousand victims 300,000 rapists and
300,000 families that are suffering
because we don't have the money well
this bill would give by five hundred
million dollars so we would have the
money 25 million dollars for the Kirk
Bloodsworth DNA testing program that
would help states like North Carolina
defray the cost to help people out of
jail help people out of death row you
know this thing is simple for me
very simple if
eleventh if I could go to Christian
school in 11th 12th grade with no
criminal record no criminal history no
nothing it's easy it's too easy for
people to play this type of game who can
win who can lose who puts on the best
show is who wins by the virtue if you
have $100,000 you're gonna lose if you
got nothing you gonna lose he still
might not win but he got a better shot
that you're gonna lose f we barely
winning talked to my family for less
than $100,000 my father don't have that
much money he worked all his life he's
76 years old and can't retire because of
what happened it's this simple if it can
happen to me it can happen to anybody
in this room thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Kirk you know the the irony of
course is if the prosecutors from
Baltimore County Maryland and the state
of Maryland had had its way Kirk
Bloodsworth would have been executed
about 17 years ago and since Kirk fought
for his freedom and proved his innocence
through DNA literally hundreds of other
inmates since he paved the way hundreds
of other inmates who are in prison on
death row have been freed and proven to
be innocent and I think our entire
nation is beginning to wake up those are
just cases where DNA is available you've
got to keep in mind most cases there is
no DNA and those are just cases where
DNA is available and somebody's been
lucky enough to get a lawyer from an
Innocence Project like from the
University of North Carolina or from
Cardozo law school to take up there
cause it's pretty frightening when you
begin to extrapolate just how many
people we maybe can have convicted over
the past 15 20 50 hundred years who are
innocent and people need to appreciate
that when you convict an innocent man or
an innocent woman
that's a victim it's a victim of a crime
just as much as anybody else as a victim
you have a victim who's been wrongly
convicted you have a family destroyed
the family of that victim and you had a
guilty person a criminal walking free to
criminalize other people it's a serious
run I think we need to address and I
think we should be thankful to Kirk for
what he's done and the tremendous
example he's sent we're going to take
some questions a few questions and
answers but before we do that we're
honored with by the presence of a couple
of other people tonight we just like to
recognize and Kirk is going to introduce
them briefly
possibility of being more than one
innocent person in this room
anybody want to take a guess on that
well if I told you there was three here
Allen girl spent nine years behind bars
five of them on death row waiting for
his execution for a murder he did not
commit Gail was sentences death for the
1995 shooting death of Alan ray Jenkins
in Bertie County no figures of evidence
connected gal to the crime and he was
convicted based solely on the testimony
of two teenage girls who participated in
Jenkins murder the girls were allowed to
plea bargained for lesser charges
exchange for their testimony in 2002 or
rejections of the Attorney General's
Office and while a five-part series on
gales case is running in the News
observer a judge ordered a new trial
because this attorney general's office
had withheld gales trial attorneys
compelling evidence of his innocence 17
witnesses said they saw the victim alive
well after the only time gal could have
been involved in a murder
many of those statements along with an
audiotape showing that a key witness
planned to Fran go were not shared with
the defense during gales trial forensic
experts agreed the victim died at the
time gale could not have committed the
crime after the judge to out gills
conviction and death sentence the
Attorney General decided to retry a girl
for murder the jury in his second trial
deliberated for less than three hours
before finding Gilliam not guilty in
later interviews jurors expressed
surprise that the state had retried yell
On February 18 2004 Allen Gale was
released in prison after spending nine
years in jail for a crime he didn't
commit
he's paralyzed first death row inmate
exonerated standing up my land
and the third fella I'm not gonna be to
much fanfare for him he harden in the
back but that's Chris Conover back there
and he's he's listening resides here in
North Carolina he was right into prison
with me way back when and knows some of
the horrors I was talking about tonight
and I want you all give him a big hand
to Nancy do we have time for a few
questions
okay yes ma'am you need to wait for the
you're gonna be on the TV inspiration I
wanted to thank you for telling your
story and my question is did any of the
other prosecutors or the original judge
or the police ever contact you
personally to apologize well the
original prosecutor in my case did come
down to the Burger King house talking
about her the a couple police officers
but the two main homicide detectives
have never apologized in her since
retired and won't be won't let nobody
talk to him presses try to call him and
I like know what you got to say nope
nope he just you know people you know
you have to understand some folks are
like that but they're they're living a
lie myself to sticking her head in the
sand they need to get it out and and do
it I appreciate the settlement oh dear
thank you so much
actually that both of the judges in
Kirk's case agreed to spend a lot of
time talking to me when I was
researching the book and both of them
expressed sorrow over the verdict and
for the fact and student talk to me do
also the that's true also the the juror
though the foreperson of perk second
trial appeared with Kirk on Oprah and
publicly apologised correct I love that
yes ma'am
thirty-eight senators I think isn't John
Edwards or senator he's one of them he's
one yep and my one of my senators Paul
sarbanes and Maryland and 2036 others
are supporting and Senator Leahy we it's
got bipartisan support from Senator hats
from Utah and you know he's horrible
Republican and but he you know he don't
want nobody to be innocent in jail like
like me or rape victims who need their
tests done and he supported we getting a
lot of support from from the hill and I
got I'm gonna applaud you know since I'm
down here at the to Senator Edwards yes
wait for the mic mister Bloodworth the
the two prosecutors who withheld
exculpatory evidence in mr. gales case
which put him on death row for five
years have been engaged today all day
today we expect all day tomorrow in
disciplinary hearings before the North
Carolina State Bar they have admitted
that they withheld the exculpatory
evidence but they defended their actions
by saying we didn't read the file we
didn't know that this information was in
the file because we didn't read it and
we really weren't prepared to understand
what exculpate ory evidence was so it's
sort of the deaf dumb and blind defense
ignorance isn't it face that that's
that's right anyway we're quite
concerned the people in the criminal
defense community are quite concerned
that the State Bar is not going to
really take any meaningful sanction
against these prosecutors
and I was just wondering from a personal
perspective what do you think is the
appropriate sanction for these
prosecutors should they be prosecuted
criminally if the State Bar does not
take action against them well that would
have to be up to mr. Gill here I mean I
think he definitely got a case and also
personally I think it should be
disbarred that's just my opinion I mean
you know if you run a stop sign
don't say you see it but you go and do
you're gonna hit a truck and that's what
they did
you got some running to do yes sir
before you leave this world is there any
change to the justice system that if
came about would make you feel it was
worthwhile the years that were stolen
from you by the justice system do not
have Alan gales in prison or Chris
Conover's or Kirk Bloodsworth ever again
and quite frankly as long as that could
happen they need to hold a death penalty
out to sea
[Applause]
I don't know if it's in there but I was
curious if it's written in the book how
you met your wife and if not can you
tell us that's a secret yes yes some
talk you gotta be specialist take movie
one of the things that you spoke about
was what life was like in the
penitentiary and I'm wondering the kind
of treatment that you received being in
this place where your life was in danger
where the temperature was always wrong
it was way too hot or way too cold it
sounds like that you were tortured
basically on a day-to-day basis and I
have a sense that that's what prison
life is like like for a lot of people
can you speak to this the injustice of
incarceration in general even for people
who have committed their crime well you
know you're sent to prison as punishment
not for punishment you know what I mean
you can't be punished more than taking
away from society and you know people
fret I mean that's something to be
taking away from society these places
are brutal they live by a code they live
we all live by a code in there I mean
and a lot of people don't follow that
code especially the people running it
and you know you can't you your two
sides pit against each other and it's a
sweat box it's hot it's brutal the guys
in there and so let's face it that's why
we got prisons to keep people like that
there but somehow somewhere people who
take power and they just you know they
get big in on this power trip and they
start doing things like closing the
windows and stuff like that and I mean
that's just mall compared to some of the
stuff we've seen you know I've seen
guards go right down on a man it almost
choked him right out
and in whether you're innocent and
guilty no person no person not in our
society should have to deal with that
because that's putting ourselves down to
their level and I don't think that's
right and as long as we have that in
this world we need to stop doing
something to change it fix it do
whatever you can to make you sing right
the man that was on your shirt wouldn't
let let that stuff happen anybody else
yes because I actually am an attorney
representing someone on death row right
now who's innocent bless your heart okay
and I think you said that it was someone
said you the first person exonerated I
happen to teach a class yesterday I had
the list of the hundred and sixteen
people that have been exonerated only uh
only a handful of them really got
exonerated on count of DNA right it's
like five percent worries me is knowing
firsthand that I've been trying to fight
for a guy for the past eight years and
getting nowhere because of the same kind
of the same kind of problems that you
face and you know I just wanted to let
people know 116 people and Counting
because as a criminal defense attorney
I cringe at wondering how many other
people are there that don't have
attorneys willing you know for eight
nine years to keep fighting for them or
have clients like yourself that keep
fighting for themselves
well you know to add to what you're
saying there's 3,500 people on death
roads throughout the United States and
according to the current statistics
since 1976 the roads have been released
and exonerated
one out of eight or innocent one out of
eight you wouldn't take a bus ride if it
was going to crash one out of eight
times which and well you know I'm not
trying to be flippers it mean it's the
facts these things are laid radar form
and the powers that be in some of the
judicial circles and political circles
seem to think that that's
we're not tough on crime this is a death
penalty book notice it and this is an
innocent book this is about innocent man
as his life and there's many many people
one sitting right down one in the back
and who knows how many people have been
executed over the years and if we can't
get it right turn out the light just
stop it
you know I'd rather put them in prison
at least they're gonna have a chance to
try to get out someday and I applaud
your efforts there and I hope you
succeed and saving that man's life one
way or the other
[Applause]
I would like to have Alan jeal tell us
what he is doing now I'm very impressed
with the turn that his life is made
would you tell us that please
anyway this year been working really
hard on getting North Carolina to pass a
moratorium on executions I don't hope
everybody in here some Foreman knows
what it is if not it's a two-year halt
on executing people here in North
Carolina while we look at some of the
problems we have with our system it's
been to me it seems like it's been going
fairly well get support for the
moratorium and I think we'll probably
get it passed this session but on that's
something that I've been working on and
also now I'm a full-time student trying
to get a degree so I can practice Social
Work I want to be a social worker kind
of dedicate my life to helping others
but that's basically what I've done for
the first six months it was spent solely
on trying to get the moratorium passed
now I'm doing both working on getting it
passed and going to school
[Applause]